what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with the
conclusion to flash war and it's
actually pretty cool and it's sort of
interesting there's actually a huge
consequence that well really two big
consequences that come out of this this
whole thing one of which you may or may
not care about the other of which most
of you will be pretty excited about so
it's it's a it's a pretty cool thing
here it's pretty awesome I remember a
little bit of ketchup here basically the
Wally West villain a hunter zolomon is
looking to travel into the past and
essentially prevent the loss of his legs
you know basically make his life what he
wanted it to be the problem with this
and what the way it kind of works is
this one of those things were like
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
what this means is that along the way of
trying to gain you're trying to trying
to travel into the past and fix his life
more or less hunter zolomon had
discovered that there was the Speed
Force which is where speedsters derive
their power from but there was also the
sage force and the strength force the
sage force basically be more like a
psychic force and then the strength
force being where people draw their
strength from now what Joshua Williamson
hasn't really done here is tie this into
the greater DC universe and he may not
and what I mean by that is if the Speed
Force is where speedsters draw their
power from then is the strength Force
where like Superman and like Solomon
Grundy and like you know super strong
characters is that where they draw their
strength from and like all the psychics
and people like that do they draw their
power from a sage force is that how that
works that may or may not be tied in DC
usually keeps things can find a
character-driven arc so like a Batman
story arc Superman story arc flash story
arc but we don't know if in this
instance these forces will spill over
into the rest of the DC universe and say
well you know this also affects Superman
and so on and so forth there's no reason
to believe they don't because the Speed
Force permeates the entirety of reality
but only the speedsters can tap into the
Speed Force and use Speed Force powers
and so because of that it's it's it's
kind of interesting it's really a fun
little caveat even so for the most part
it was basically flash or I'm sorry it
was Wally and Barry trying to track down
or trying to stop hunter zolomon and
keep him from going crazy the problem is
that with all these new powers there's
really not much that they can do to stop
him
now the other thing here is that because
of what he's doing because of the fact
that he basically ran to the Past and
started changing things up what this man
is that he was essentially eradicating
the 25th century where he comes from and
that's the reason why you have like
commander cold who's from the 25th
century iris West and
and and you know new 52 Wally West who
are just kind of stranded in this void
more or less this what would be the 20th
such 25th century but isn't there
anymore now the way in which hunter
zolomon was able to do this was by
manipulating something called hyper time
now hyper time is a weird idea a very
weird idea in the realm of DC companies
the best way I know how to say it so
take DC's publishing comic book era like
when they were publishing comic books
between like 1938 when Superman first
showed up in like 1984 basically what
you had is you had like different earths
quote-unquote they were given like
numerical designation so you had earth
one or two or three or four and the
numerical designation was designed to do
nothing more than to basically say this
is a different universe that's all it
was for what DC did is they said these
universes have always existed earth too
is the age of world war two superheroes
you know the Golden Age of superheroes
basically and then earth s was were
she's AM that's where the whole Shazam
family was and earth one is all the
superhero stories and involved you know
Barry Allen and that Justice League team
and someone supporting all that ran
until about 1984 when it became too
convoluted and complicated to understand
for new fans anyway and so DC cut it all
loose they dropped it they canceled all
that stuff with crisis on Infinite
Earths and after that they said now
there's only one universe and that ran
for about fourteen years and the reason
why is because of 99 Grant Morrison and
Mark Waid had this idea of saying yeah
but like we want the multiverse back but
we can't really have it back and so what
they did is they created hyper time and
hyper time was DC's attempt to copy
marvel's multiverse in Marvel Comics you
only ever had one universe but then like
a thing would happen where you would
create like a divergent universe based
on that so like in the main Marvel
Universe Peter Parker gains the venom
suit right the Venom symbiote suit and
then in the main Marvel Universe he
travels back to earth and he meets with
Reed Richards and Reed Richards says
actually that suit that you're wearing
is alive it's a living breathing
organism you should get rid of it if so
Peter goes to a bell tower he starts
ringing the bells the suit hates the
sound all the you know all the pain and
everything and leaves and then
eventually bonds to Eddie Brock thus
venom is born an alternate reality would
be what is spider-man never stopped
being venom then like that would be an
alternate reality story but that
alternate universe exists because it
branches off of the main Marvel Universe
DC tried to copy that and what they said
is in addition to branching off
sometimes it'll loop back and intersect
with the mainland or with the main DC
Universe the problem is that it was
actually more complicated than the
multiverse they had before
and it seemed really really unnecessary
and so fans didn't really like it too
much now all that turned out to be a
moot purpose because in 2006 they
brought the multiverse back with
Infinite Crisis but it was an attempt to
kind of have the multiverse without
actually having the multiverse and so
that's kind of what Joshua Williamson is
doing here that Hypertime exists but
this is only a temporary thing because
as they're running through and as
they're literally like racing through
and we're seeing like these different
realities these different universes you
know we're really these different points
in time where you have like the
flashpoint fight between Barry Allen and
ER Thawne you've got Barry dying during
crisis on Infinite Earths you have like
all these different eras in in the in
history of DC you also have like giant
Irish who really it's like them as
adults in the future and so it's kind of
cool to see this thing unfold because as
they're racing through they're actually
seeing their life the way it could have
been because hunter zolomon is changing
things as he's racing through time like
the very act of doing it is is
essentially changing things here and
they're not massive things but things
that are small enough that they could
have effects later on they can basically
create ripple effects all throughout the
timestream they can have like big
ramifications and so it's kind of cool
here because like when they're going
through hunter zolomon whole stances
like but I don't understand why you're
trying to stop me though because Barry
did it so why is it okay for Barry but
it's not okay for me Yoenis in is
interesting because Wally had the exact
same stance
you know when Wally was like I want to
go back in time and I want to stop all
this I'm happening so I can have giant
iris you now wanna prevent Manhattan or
whoever it was from messing with the
timestream so Leo nobody forgets these
last 10 years and I've got my kids and
so on so forth Barry's like no no no you
can't do that and in the way that Barry
comes off here that's kind of the funny
thing the way the Barry comes off here
both to Wally and even hunter zolomon is
don't do as I do do as I say do if you
go through and start changing time
you're gonna screw things up in really
bad ways that you can't even really
imagine and when you go back to change
it you can never go back to the things
the way they were supposed to be or at
least that's the opinion Barry has of
course we know they were because of what
Manhattan did things didn't but still
the fact remains here that it's
interesting because hunter zolomon I
mean initially was not going back in
time now he's kind of gone mad with
power so he's like I'll create universe
you'll free the universe to my liking
and everything will be the way I want it
to be and it's kind of it's a little
disappointing
um I mean joshua williamson is an
incredible writer but it's a little
disappointing because hunter zolomon
kind of falls into the cliche villain
role like I have this amazing scheme and
this amazing desire and you know it's so
human because all I want to do is just
change my past and keep crappy things
from happening to me but now
I've got all this power I'm gonna remake
reality in my image and it's just kind
of like okay I understand but like I
kind of like it seems a little cliche
but even then like it's still a cool
idea that's one of the reasons why
Joshua williamson's flash writing is so
awesome because by and large the
characters are so human and so solid in
terms of how they're being written and
how they're being you know how they're
being given to us and so the fight here
is actually pretty awesome is basically
a speedster fight but as they're going
through and as they're literally facing
off against each other
what is up happening is that it's kind
of hard to explain when you have Wally
fighting against hunter zolomon he
almost creates like these Speed Force
constructs
now when I say creates create Speed
Force constructs I don't mean like
creating like speed horse lightning or
something like that what I mean is
actually creating what are essentially
flash equivalent of like green lantern
hard light constructs and these come in
the form of like Jay Garrick and joy and
iris and like max mercury and it's just
like these speedsters we haven't seen in
forever because it's kind like you know
my family runs with me that kind of a
thing and so that's that's why these
moments are awesome that's why these
things are so important is because this
is like a like a one little moment thing
and like when the story ends it could be
like in the next in the next issue
Barry's kind of like so let's talk about
those constructs you made Wally it's
like yeah man I have no idea what that
was or how that works but like we should
try it again and suddenly he's like
sending people after you know things you
know sweet force constructs after people
but more so than that it's kind of
joshua williamson's tribute to like the
speed to the to the the flash mythos
because if you're somebody who picked up
with a flash in DC we were and never
read anything before and then flash fans
will tell you you're really missing out
because people who sit down who have
been reading the flash for years and
years and years and years running all
the way back to like Geoff Johns flash
rebirth the original flash rebirth and
even before that they look at people
like max mercury they look at impulse
Bart Allen they look at Jay Garrick
these different members of the flash
family that's like but it's not a
complete family yet because all you have
really right now is Wally and Barry and
new 52 Wally and that's really about it
this cohesive family unit of flashes
doesn't really exist or at least it's
not there right now and so it kind of
leaves people wanting to see that return
and so for people you know who are
looking at this as kind of a small
glimpse of how things could be where all
these different speeches are gonna start
making their return and so it's it's
kind of a it's a really good sort of
feel-good moment you know what kind of
hits people right in the fields you know
with regards to how they feel about the
flash mythos and the speeches they want
to see return and all that kind of good
stuff and so essentially what is up
happening is you you basically have in
the aftermath of the all the way of all
this because it was happened
with hunter zolomon the speedforce has
in fact been broken and the result here
is that while speedsters can still tap
into the Speed Force and what it means
is that with it being fractured
there's no means to travel back and
forth through time basically hyper times
gone it's destroyed
time travel is destroyed legs like
speedsters cannot run back and forth
through time now this is with regards to
speedsters and that's why I like this
age and strength force are two
distinctly different things because when
it comes to speedsters traveling like
running back and forth through time
originally that all started with very
Allen's ability to like vibrate through
dimensional walls right like to drive it
to vibrate through these sort of
Universal barriers that separated one
universe from another now that went away
after crisis on Infinite Earths and
because that went away the question was
well what's Wally's ability gonna be
what's gonna make him unique and
comparison to everybody else well just
let him be so fast he can run back and
forth through time I just just have that
be the case for Wally effort for Wally
West which was that was his thing like
he was able to mainline the Speed Force
and by doing so run back and forth
through ton very had to use a cosmic
treadmill to do that even before he died
when you're talking about this it
basically means that like the ability to
move back and forth from one point in
time to another to change history
doesn't exist anymore for the speedsters
now initially kind of seems like okay
well that's that's cool I guess but
that's a pretty big moment actually it's
a pretty significant thing because what
it means is no more flash points what's
going to happen at least as far as
Joshua williamson's writing goes is from
the time he's from it from this point
until the time he stops writing then
there will never be an instance of
time-travel it'll never be an instance
where they will run back into the past
and quote unquote fixed things and
that's actually a genius idea because a
problem with time travel because bindus
was really really guilty of this back in
the day but the problem of time-travel
is this basically used by writers to
write themselves out of a hole it's like
well I mean I I have this really cool
story and like you know it was it was
awesome up into the end but I don't know
how to fix it so time-travel and they
just jump back in the past but with with
Hypertime with the inability of Flash's
being able to travel back and forth
through time what it means is that
Joshua Williams is basically telling us
as long as I'm writing the flash
consequences of consequences when
something happens that thing is
happening now after Joshua Williamson
leaves then it could very well be that
well you know somebody will use time
travel and fix things and so on and so
forth that's the nature of writers
writers just kind of been stories to
their own whim and write whatever
stories they want so long as you know
editorials okay with it and fans don't
give them too much hate but still that's
really kind of the big thing here but
the big
the big takeaway from all of this is
that as a direct result of the actions
of essentially breaking the speedforce a
speedster has returned another speedster
has popped up and this speedster is bart
allen also known as impulse not bart
not the crazy religious guy from
the future but the original bart allen
and this is a huge moment now if you
want to know more about Bart Allen
check out my video down in the
description I have a video on Bart Allen
explain where we've run over his whole
character but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comest explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah let me know you guys think
about this story and I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]